Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, 12 Days of Christmas special. And Dominic, today it's the 2nd of January. Yes. Did anything important happen on the 2nd of January? And if it did, is it perhaps Spanish themed? It is Spanish themed, yes.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》圣诞十二日特别节目。多米尼克，今天是1月2日。是的。1月2日发生过什么重要的事情吗？如果有的话，它是不是跟西班牙有关？是的，确实跟西班牙有关。
So it's a huge event in world history, Tom. It's the reconquest of Granada. So you've been to Granada, I assume? I have, yeah. The Alhambra? Several times, yeah. It's a magnificent palace, for those people who don't know, on the rock overlooking the city.
所以这是世界历史上一件大事，汤姆。这就是格拉纳达的收复之战。所以我猜你去过格拉纳达？我去过，是的。阿尔罕布拉宫？去过好几次，是的。对于那些不知道的人来说，它是一座宏伟的宫殿，坐落在俯瞰城市的岩石上。
This great sort of ornament of Islamic Spain. And so what's called the Reconquista has been going on for centuries, effectively, the Christian reconquest of Spain. And so what's called the Reconquista has been going on for centuries, effectively, the Christian reconquest of Spain. Now that in itself is quite a loaded term, and one I think that a lot of historians would be a little bit suspicious of now, don't you? Because, I mean, they would argue
它是伊斯兰西班牙的一大装饰。因此，所谓的“收复失地运动”实际上已经持续了几个世纪，也就是基督徒对西班牙的收复。因此，所谓的“收复失地运动”实际上已经持续了几个世纪，也就是基督徒对西班牙的收复。现在，这个词本身就带有很强的倾向性，而且我认为现在很多历史学家对此都会心存疑虑，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，他们会争辩说……
that it's not a kind of reconquest so much as the creation of something that hadn't previously existed. I think it is a reconquest as well. Do you think it's a reconquest? It's a reconquest so much as the creation of something that hadn't previously existed. I think it is a reconquest as well. Do you think it's a reconquest? It's a reconquest by Christian rulers of lands that had previously been Christian. I don't really have a problem with calling it that.
与其说这是一种收复，不如说是创造了一种以前并不存在的东西。我也认为这是一次收复。你觉得这是一次收复吗？与其说这是一种收复，不如说是创造了一种以前并不存在的东西。我也认为这是一次收复。你觉得这是一次收复吗？这是基督教统治者对以前曾属于基督教的土地的收复。我真的不觉得叫这个名字有什么问题。
You see, what I don't like about that is that that seems to imply that the Islamic sort of societies that have been there were intruders newcomers whereas they've been there for centuries i mean to use my example that i used in yesterday's podcast they have been there for far longer than the united states has existed yeah of course i'm not denying that but i'm but but i think that uh i mean the reconquista is obviously a spanish word coined by the spanish christians who themselves um and i think it adequately reflects what how they understood Conquista is obviously a Spanish word coined by the Spanish Christians themselves. And I think it adequately reflects how they understood the process.
你看，我对这个词不满的地方在于，它似乎暗示了曾经存在那里的伊斯兰社会是入侵者、新来者，然而他们已经在那里存在了几个世纪了。借用我在昨天的播客中用过的例子，他们存在的的时间比美国存在的时间还要长得多。是的，当然，我并不是要否认这一点，但是——但是我认为，呃，我的意思，“收复失地运动”（Reconquista）显然是一个西班牙语词汇，是由西班牙基督徒自己创造的，他们自己，呃，我认为这充分反映了他们是如何理解——“收复失地运动”（Reconquista）显然是一个西班牙语词汇，是由西班牙基督徒自己创造的。我认为这充分反映了他们对这一进程的理解。
It does. But you don't think it's loaded? You don't think it's very loaded? Well, I think there's a kind of desire on the part of people to see pre-Reconquista Spain as some multicultural paradise. And I think that that was really, really bred of the tensions in the first decade of the 21st century. There was a real desire to say, yeah, there was a time where Muslims and Christians and Jews all got on really well, and they all sat around eating oranges and talking about Aristotle,
确实如此。但你不觉得这个词带有倾向性吗？你不觉得它倾向性很强吗？嗯，我认为人们有一种愿望，想要把收复失地运动之前的西班牙视为某种多元文化的乌托邦。我认为这实际上是由21世纪头十年里的种种紧张局势催生出来的。当时有一种强烈的愿望，想要去宣称：是的，曾几何时，穆斯林、基督徒和犹太人相处得非常融洽，他们坐在一起吃着橘子，讨论着亚里士多德……
bubbling fountains, all this kind of stuff. Philosophy. Yes. And so the word Reconquista seemed, well, problematic in that context. But I think that's a fantasy. Islamic rule was incredibly brutal. Christian rule was incredibly brutal.
潺潺的喷泉，诸如此类的东西。哲学。是的。所以在这种背景下，“收复失地运动”这个词似乎就显得……嗯，有些问题了。但我觉得这只是一种幻想。伊斯兰统治极其残酷。基督教统治也极其残酷。
The process was about war. The idea that there, of course, there were, there was Jews and Christians and Muslims did commune because they all lived cheek by jowl. There was kind of scholarly communication. But in Muslim lands, Christians and Jews were decisively subordinate. And in Christian lands, Jews and Muslims were decisively subordinate.
这个过程关乎战争。当然，那里曾经有过犹太人、基督徒和穆斯林的交流，因为他们都比邻而居。某种学术交流是存在的。但在穆斯林统治的土地上，基督徒和犹太人处于明显的从属地位；而在基督教统治的土地上，犹太人和穆斯林也处于明显的从属地位。
And I think the attempt to imagine that this was some kind of paradise is wholly bogus. Well, we can get into this. The language of conquest, I think, is important because it reflects the brute realities of what we're going on. OK, we can get into this in more detail in a future podcast. It's great to find a subject on which I can pretend to be more progressive. So that is splendid. Let's get back to the anniversary. So the 2nd of January, 1492, the final war really in rolling up the Islamic kingdoms of Southern Spain
我认为，试图将这想象成某种天堂的想法完全是虚假的。嗯，我们可以深入探讨这个话题。我认为征服的语言很重要，因为它反映了正在发生的残酷现实。好吧，我们可以在未来的播客中更详细地探讨这个问题。很高兴能找到一个我可以假装自己更进步的主题。这真是太棒了。让我们回到这个周年纪念日上来。所以，1492年1月2日，真正旨在瓦解西班牙南部伊斯兰王国的最后一场战争……
has been launched the previous April. And that's the Granada War, the attack on the last Islamic emirate. And it's been launched, obviously, by Ferdinand and Isabella, the most Catholic monarchs, as they are known. So Ferdinand of Aragon and Isabella of Castile, who are going to unite to create Spain.
已经在前一年的4月打响了。这就是格拉纳达战争，对最后一个伊斯兰埃米尔国的进攻。这场战争显然是由天主教双王——斐迪南和伊莎贝拉发动的。因此，阿拉贡的斐迪南和卡斯蒂利亚的伊莎贝拉联合起来创建了西班牙。
Granada is isolated. It is friendless. Its allies have been defeated or basically lost their nerve. So for what become the Spanish, it's actually a relatively easy job to kind of surround it and subdue it the um grenadans issue appeals to the ottomans to north africa and so on but basically everybody ignores them because they know it's a kind of complete lost cause um then there's a very strange kind of, it's almost like a Brexit deal process. So in November 1491, the attackers agree a kind of pre-truce truce with the defenders.
格拉纳达被孤立了。它孤立无援。它的盟友们已经被击败，或者基本上丧失了斗志。因此，对于后来成为西班牙人的人来说，包围并征服它其实是一件相对容易的事情。呃，格拉纳达人向奥斯曼人、向北非等地发出呼吁，但基本上所有人都忽视了他们，因为大家都知道这是一场彻底彻底的必输之局。呃，接着发生了一件非常奇怪的事情，几乎就像是一个英国脱欧式的谈判过程。所以在1491年11月，进攻方与防守方达成了一种“准停战协议”。
And they sort of say, well, we'll pause while we discuss the details of the truce. And then the final deal is done in time for the 2nd of January. And that's the day that even now in Granada they celebrate it. They have marches and processions and they have sort of this great fiesta because this is the death knell of Muslim Spain and the moment that a kind of new Spain is born. So the guy who is in charge of Granada, he's about in his early 30s, he's about 32, and his actual name is Abu Abdallah Muhammad the 12th but he's known
他们有点像是说，好吧，在我们讨论停战细节的同时，我们先停火。然后最终协议在1月2日之前达成。直到今天，格拉纳达人在这一天仍在庆祝。他们有游行、巡游，还有盛大的节日，因为这是穆斯林西班牙的丧钟，也是一个新西班牙诞生的时刻。所以，当时负责管理格拉纳达的那个人，大概三十岁出头，大约32岁，他的真名叫阿布·阿卜杜拉·穆罕默德十二世，但西班牙编年史家称他为……
to Spanish chroniclers as Boabdil sort of corruption of Abdallah and Boabdil rides out with about 80 of his men on the 2nd of January to the camp on the on the banks of the river which is sort of facing the fort the Alhamb, to Ferdinand of Aragon's camp. And there in this sort of, this great sort of set piece. Tableau, isn't it? Scene, absolutely. Clash of Civilizations tableau. By so many Spanish painters and so on,
博阿布迪尔（Boabdil），这是对“阿卜杜拉”的一个讹称。在1月2日，博阿布迪尔骑着马，带着大约80名随从，来到了河岸边的军营。那个军营正对着阿尔罕布拉堡，也就是阿拉贡国王斐迪南的军营。就在这里，在这场盛大的、宛如精心排演的……一幅画面，对吧？一个场景，绝对是的。一场文明冲突的画面。许多西班牙画家等等都描绘过这个场景……
he hands over the keys to the city, to Ferdinand, basically in surrenders. And the great thing about this tableau, Tom, is that one of the people who is there and watching is Christopher Columbus, is a young Italian who has been pestering Ferdinand and Isabella to pay for his plans to go into India. And of course, it's Christopher Columbus.
他将城市的钥匙交给了斐迪南，基本上就是投降了。汤姆，这个画面的妙处在于，当时在场观看的人当中，有一个是克里斯托弗·哥伦布，他是一个年轻的意大利人，一直缠着斐迪南和伊莎贝拉资助他的远航印度计划。当然，这就是克里斯托弗·哥伦布。
And later on, we have a letter that Christopher Columbus writes to Ferdinand and Isabella when he's sucking up to them. And he says, I remember seeing the royal banners of your highnesses planted by force of arms on the towers of the Alhambra. So he's there watching this extraordinary landmark moment, which for a lot of people, I think you could say, is the end, you know, it's one of those, when do the Middle Ages end? Yeah. I mean, this is one of those moments, the end of Islamic Spain, the moment that the balance, you could argue, that the balance between the West and Islam, for want of a better expression,
后来，我们保留了一封克里斯托弗·哥伦布在阿谀奉承斐迪南和伊莎贝拉时写给他们的信。他在信中说：“我记得曾看到殿下的皇家旗帜以武力插在阿尔罕布拉宫的塔楼上。”所以他就在现场，见证了这个非凡的历史性时刻。对于许多人来说，你可以说这就是终结，你知道的，这就是“中世纪何时结束”的时刻。是的。我的意思是，这就是那些时刻之一，伊斯兰西班牙的结束，你可以说，西方与伊斯兰之间力量对比（恕我用这个更好的词）……
begins to tip. Of course, you've got the high points of the Ottoman Empire to come. But, from this point onwards, Spain is unified and created, and Spain is going to,
开始发生倾斜的时刻。当然，奥斯曼帝国的全盛时期还在后面。但是，从这一刻起，西班牙实现了统一和创建，并且西班牙……
of course, become the great superpower. So, there's one more moment, which is the moment. This is his mum. It is his mum. His mum. The moment everybody remembers.
当然，也将成为伟大的超级大国。所以，还有一个时刻，就是那个时刻。这是他的妈妈。确实是他的妈妈。他的妈妈。所有人都铭记的那个时刻。
So he, if you've ever been to Granada, it's surrounded by mountains. The Albujaras, I think they're called. We almost went on holiday up in the mountains. Very windy roads. Anyway,
所以他——如果你去过格拉纳达，就会发现它被群山环抱。阿尔普哈拉斯（Albujaras），我想它们是这么叫的。我们差点去山里度假。道路非常蜿蜒。总之……
so he's winding up into the, into the mountains, into Exarch. He's going to go to Morocco, to Fez fez and spend the rest of his days in fez and the story goes always told by spanish kind of folklorists that he stops at this kind of ridge and he looks back over at the alhambra the great pink stone walls in the dying sunlight the sound of these beautiful buildings in the world. Oh, tremendous. This vision of Paramount's ground is created to be a paradise.
于是他蜿蜒着进入山中，进入阿尔罕布拉宫的后山（Exarch）。他将前往摩洛哥的非斯（Fez），在非斯度过余生。故事是这样的，西班牙的民间传说总是这样讲述的：他在某个山脊停了下来，回望阿尔罕布拉宫——那些在夕阳下泛着红光的巨大石墙，世界上这些美丽建筑的声音……哦，太壮观了。这番旨在成为天堂的帕拉毛德山（Paramount's ground）的愿景被创造了出来。
And it is a paradise, isn't it? Absolutely. I mean, it is one of the most beautiful buildings. And he looks back and Boabdil and he weeps. He sobs. And his mother, his mum, says to him, I know. Now you weep like a woman over what you could not defend as a man.
它确实是一个天堂，不是吗？绝对是的。我的意思是，它是最美丽的建筑之一。他回过头去，博阿布迪尔哭了。他泣不成声。他的母亲，他的妈妈对他说：“我知道。现在你像个女人一样哭泣，为了你没能像个男人一样去捍卫的东西。”
If your mum said that to you, you'd never recover. Would you? I mean, that would scar you for life. So that's called, I mean, his sigh is called The Moor's Last Sigh. So as in the Salman Rushdie book? Salman Rushdie book. And the pass where he supposedly stops is called The Pass of The Moor's Sigh. That is very romantic.
如果你的妈妈对你这么说，你这辈子都缓不过劲来，对吧？我的意思是，那会给你留下终生的心理阴影。所以这个地方被称为——他的叹息被称为“摩尔人的最后叹息”。就像萨尔曼·鲁西迪的书里那样？萨尔曼·鲁西迪的书。他据此驻足的山隘被称为“摩尔人叹息隘口”。这非常浪漫。
It's a very romantic story. But actually what then happens is pretty unromantic. So you get the sort of the forcible conversion of a lot of the Moors, the Moriscos. Because actually the treaty is pretty generous. It is. So there's no forced conversion. And even Christians who've converted to Islam don't have to convert back.
这是一个非常浪漫的故事。但实际上接下来发生的事情却一点也不浪漫。你会看到许多摩尔人（Moriscos）遭到强制改宗。因为实际上之前的条约相当宽厚。确实如此。所以没有强制改宗。甚至连那些曾改信伊斯兰教的基督徒也不必改回去。
But the Spanish soon renege on that. And they start, there starts to be this series of kind of force conversions, expulsions mariscos, exactly confiscation of property and so on a whole, I mean one of the biggest
但西班牙人很快就食言了。他们开始背信弃义，随后发生了一系列强制改宗、驱逐摩尔人（Mariscos）的事件，准确地说，还有没收财产等等，整个……我的意思是，其中规模最大的一波……
I mean it goes on for ages so one of the biggest waves of expulsions comes at the beginning of the 17th century I mean you're talking about a massive movement of people, refugee kind of crisis. So tens of thousands of people going to North Africa. And it's not just Muslims, is it?
我的意思是，这持续了很长时间，其中最大的一波驱逐潮发生在17世纪初。我是说，这涉及大规模的人口迁移，一种难民危机。成千上万的人前往北非。而且不仅仅是穆斯林，对吧？
No. So there are three kind of seismic events that happen in this year. So the fall of Granada, Columbus's voyage across the Atlantic, and the expulsion of the Jews. Exactly. So actually the fall of Granada creates this momentum for a unified Christian Spain in which the Muslims and the Jews do not belong.
是的。所以在这一年里发生了三件重大的震撼性事件。格拉纳达的陷落、哥伦布横渡大西洋的航行，以及驱逐犹太人。没错。事实上，格拉纳达的陷落为建立一个统一的基督教西班牙创造了势头，在这个国家里，穆斯林和犹太人是没有容身之地的。
And so you get the expulsion of the Jews who, of course, tens of thousands of people who end up going to Italy, to Greece, to North Africa, and that's the origin of the kind of Sephardicic jewish branch and it's a massive diaspora yeah colossal huge into places like you know i don't know smyrna thessaloniki and so on um and the ottomans of course they you know can't believe that the spaniards are being so stupid exactly expelling all these you these incredibly able and wealthy people. But it's it's some. I mean, to us, it seems I mean, it's kind of the ultimate crime, isn't it?
于是你看到了驱逐犹太人的行动，当然，成千上万的人最终流亡到意大利、希腊、北非，这就是西班牙犹太人（Sephardic Jewish）分支的起源，这是一场巨大的散居——是的，极其庞大，涌向诸如……我不知道，士麦那、塞萨洛尼基等等地方。奥斯曼人当然觉得西班牙人怎么会这么愚蠢，竟然把这些极其能干且富有的犹太人都驱逐出境。但这是……我的意思是，对我们来说，这似乎……我的意思是，这简直是终极罪行，不是吗？
It seems a crime against a multicultural, harmonious future. But it exists in the context of apocalyptic yearning, I think. I think Ferdinand seriously sees himself as a figure who may be destined to bring in the, you know, the second coming. He's very, very focused on the recapture of Jerusalem. And Columbus, likewise, is very, very motivated by this kind of idea that, you know, the end of the world is drawing near.
它看起来像是对一个多元文化、和谐未来的犯罪。但我认为，它存在于一种末世论的渴望之中。我认为斐迪南真的把自己视为一个注定要迎来末日审判（即基督再临）的人物。他非常非常专注于夺回耶路撒冷。同样，哥伦布也深受这种思想的驱使，认为世界末日即将来临。
And people's motives exist in a context that to us seems very very hard to get a grasp on i think i think that's absolutely right i mean i read a book a year ago by a guy called fernando cervantes um i don't think he's related to these cervantes he's a mexican historian and it's a book called conquistadoresadores. And it's a book about what happens in the same year. So basically the arrival of the Spanish in the New World. And obviously a lot of the people who arrive in the New World have been in these campaigns. So they have been fighting against the Moors.
人们的动机存在于一种对我们来说似乎很难理解的背景中，我认为……我认为这绝对正确。我的意思是，一年前我读过一本书，作者是一个叫费尔南多·塞万提斯（Fernando Cervantes）的人。我觉得他和那个塞万提斯没亲戚关系，他是一位墨西哥历史学家。这本书叫《征服者》（Conquistadores）。这本书讲的是同一年发生的事情。基本上就是西班牙人到达新世界。显然，很多到达新世界的人都曾参与过这些战役。所以他们曾与摩尔人战斗过。
And they are absolutely – one of the things that Cervantes really brings out in this book is he says, you know, we traditionally see the Spanish arrival in the new world as motivated purely by plunder and greed and cynicism and all of these kinds of things. And the Christianity is merely a fig leaf for all that. And this obviously would appeal to you, Tom. He says, no,
他们绝对——塞万提斯在这本书中真正突出的观点之一是，他说，我们传统上认为西班牙人到达新世界的动机纯粹是掠夺、贪婪、玩世不恭以及所有这些东西。而基督教只是这一切的遮羞布。这显然会吸引你，汤姆。他说，不对……
that's not right. They absolutely, the Christianity is not a fig leaf at all. They, it motivates everything and you cannot understand them. If you think of them as just as butchers and plunderers and robber barons absolutely see themselves as app so when they talk about you know for example when they talk about converting the muslims in southern spain or where they talk about converting the indians in mexico and in central america this isn't just sort of cruel repression
那是不对的。基督教绝对不是什么遮羞布。它驱动了一切，如果你把他们仅仅当作屠夫、掠夺者和强盗贵族，你是无法理解他们的。他们绝对认为自己是——所以当他们谈到，例如，当他们谈到让西班牙南部的穆斯林改宗，或者当他们谈到让墨西哥和中美洲的印第安人改宗时，这不仅仅是某种残酷的镇压……
they genuinely believe that they just they're saving these guys' souls. Absolutely. Just as in the Islamic period, the Muslim conquerors impose on Christians and Jews templates of subordination that have been established in the Quran. The cycles of conquest and dominance and exploitation on both the Muslim and the Christian side are absolutely fueled, of course, by, I mean, everybody wants to be on the top. But it is also massively fueled by very, very culturally determined ways of understanding how that dominance should be expressed. rest and i think that that with the conquistadores um you know we did that wonderful episode with
他们真心相信自己是在拯救这些人的灵魂。绝对是的。就像在伊斯兰时期，穆斯林征服者将《古兰经》中确立的从属模式强加给基督徒和犹太人一样。穆斯林和基督徒双方的征服、统治和剥削循环，当然都受到——我的意思是，每个人都想成为人上人——但它也极大地受到那些由文化决定的、关于这种统治应当如何表达的观念的驱动。我认为，对于那些征服者（Conquistadores）……你知道，我们和卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）做过那一期精彩的节目，探讨阿兹特克人和墨西加人如何看待世界，以及努力理解他们的视角是如何改变你对征服过程的理解的。我认为这完全同样适用于征服者（Conquistadores）。这就是为什么我觉得那本书也如此精彩。我认为它是卡米拉·汤森的《第五个太阳》的绝佳伴读。实际上，汤姆，这本书所做的是，在过去大约50年里，学术界有一种稍微不太好的、自动化的习惯，即声称：人们相信这个，但这其实只是一种……是的，恰好……你知道，这只是一种……借口或者托词。
camilla townsend um talking about the the aztecs and mexica how they see how they saw the world and how the effort to understand how they understood it things transforms your understanding of the process of the conquest but i think exactly the same is true of the the conquistadores and that's why i thought that book was so wonderful as well i thought it's kind of wonderful companion piece to camilla townsend's fifth son it is actually well what it does i think tom is that there's a there's a kind of slightly bad habit i think an um an automatic kind of scholarly habit in the last 50 years or so to say people believed this but this was actually merely a yeah exactly you know this was the the sort of um a pretext or
卡米拉·汤森德，呃，谈到了阿兹特克人和墨西卡人，他们是如何看待世界的，以及努力去理解他们是如何理解世界的这一过程，会改变你对征服过程的理解，但我觉得 conquistadores（西班牙征服者）也完全是这样，这就是为什么我认为那本书也那么精彩，我觉得它是卡米拉·汤森德的《第五子》的绝佳姊妹篇，它确实是，汤姆，我认为它所做的是，有一种，呃，在过去大约50年里，学术界有一种稍微有点不好的习惯，一种自动的学术习惯，就是说人们相信这个，但这其实仅仅是一个，是的，完全正确，你知道，这是一种，呃，借口或者
what they really cared about generally it's a kind of what they really cared about was money yeah um and and that's true with almost everything so people you know with culture wars people i think i mean i think they're not really cold people don't really care about culture i mean that is a kind of lingering aftershock of marxism isn't it it is exactly that everything is to be determined you know explained ultimately in material terms but i think it's also um it's a kind of a laying claim to a kind of sophistication but yeah you know i've studied history so long that i've now penetrated to uh the dark motives that fuel how people have behaved um there's i mean there's a very petty example of this in the last few years in britain which is when people talk about brexit and they, well, people who voted for Brexit didn't really do it because they didn't want to leave the EU.
他们真正关心的通常是——某种程度上，他们真正关心的是金钱，是的，嗯——几乎所有事情都是如此。所以人们，你知道的，比如文化战争中的人们，我想，我的意思是，我认为他们并不是真的……人们其实并不关心文化，我的意思是，那其实是马克思主义的一种挥之不去的余波，不是吗？完全就是这样：一切最终都要由物质条件来决定，并从物质层面来解释。但我也觉得，这也是一种……这是一种标榜自己老练的方式：“啊，你知道的，我研究历史这么久了，现在我终于看透了那些驱动人们行为的黑暗动机……”过去几年在英国，有一个非常琐碎的例子，那就是当人们谈论英国脱欧时，他们……嗯，那些投票支持脱欧的人，其实并不是因为他们不想离开欧盟。
They really did it because of racism, anti-austerity, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And, you know, this sort of I've penetrated to the deeper motives that these people themselves don't even realise they have. Yeah, well, also, you know, nobody voted for Brexit to make themselves poorer. Well, I think actually quite a lot of people did. Well, anyway. You know, there were things that were more important than that. Who knew the conversation about the conquest of the Alhambra could lead us to just a rambling conversation about Brexit?
他们这么做其实是因为种族主义、反紧缩政策，等等等等。你知道，这就属于那种“我洞察了那些人自己甚至都没意识到更深层动机”的心态。对，而且你知道的，没有人是为了让自己变穷而投票支持脱欧的。嗯，其实我觉得还真有不少人是这么想的。好吧，不管怎样。你知道，当时有比这更重要的事情。谁能想到关于征服阿尔罕布拉宫的谈话，最后会把我们引向一场关于脱欧的闲聊呢？
But, you know, you will know that this has been the great theme. That's the great theme of Dominion, is that actually it's not just about material self-interest. No, no, no. You're absolutely right. I agree with you completely. That this stuff really, really matters. Now, if you think you may have heard
但是，你知道的，你会发现这其实一直是个宏大主题。这也是《多米尼恩》（Dominion）的宏大主题，那就是这其实不仅仅关乎物质上的自利。不，不，不。你完全说得对。我完全同意你的看法。这些东西真的、真的非常重要。现在，如果你觉得自己以前可能听过
some of this from us before, you will be relieved because in the second half, we are talking about somebody we've never mentioned on the podcast and a part of the world I think we've never mentioned. We will be delving into the murky world
我们讲过其中的某些内容，那么你可以放心了，因为在下半场，我们要聊一个我们在播客中从未提及的人，以及一个我认为我们从未提及的世界角落。我们要深入探讨
of the Hawaiian monarchy. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. See you after the break. Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. I promised you the Hawaiian monarchy, and that's what you're going to get. Tom, this is not a subject I was expecting us to ever talk about on this podcast. Enlighten me. No. Well, I'm going to put my hands up and say that this is not a subject that I really know anything about at all. Well, that's a good start. Have you researched it closely?
夏威夷君主制的神秘世界。中场休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。中场休息后再见。Club。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。我向你们承诺过要讲夏威夷君主制，这就是你们将要听到的内容。汤姆，这不是一个我预料到我们会在这个播客里讨论的主题。快给我讲讲吧。不。好吧，我得主动举手承认，我对这个主题其实一无所知。嗯，这倒是个不错的开始。你仔细研究过它吗？
Well, but it's a subject that I became interested in because of a drama series that I watched last year called White Lotus. Did you see it? Brilliant series. Absolutely brilliant. last year called white lotus did you see it brilliant series absolutely i thought brilliant i mean i thought it was it was the best satire yeah the way the west is at the moment that i've seen for a long time it was it was what was nice about but you're you're i think you're almost underselling it because you can that makes it sound quite political and actually one of the great things about it was that the politics was constantly being kind of undercut. Well, that's why it's a great satire.
不过，我对这个主题产生兴趣，是因为我去年看了一部名为《白莲花度假村》（White Lotus）的电视剧。你看了吗？非常棒的剧。绝对棒极了。去年看的叫《白莲花度假村》你看了吗非常棒的剧绝对我觉得太棒了我的意思是我觉得这是我看到的很长一段时间以来关于西方现状的最佳讽刺作品，它……它好在哪里呢？不过我觉得你简直有点低估它了，因为那样说会让人觉得它非常政治化，而事实上，这部剧最棒的一点之一，就是它的政治色彩不断地在被某种程度上消解。嗯，这就是为什么它是一部伟大的讽刺作品。
Yeah. I mean, but it was also great character studies. So essentially, the plot is it's set in a hotel, a luxury hotel. Appalling rich visitors arrive. There's the staff who are exploited. And of course, the dynamic is that the rich, the white outsiders are exploitative, but it becomes more complicated than that. And it's a brilliant, brilliant series.
对。我的意思是，它也是对人物的绝佳刻画。所以本质上，剧情的设定是这样的：故事发生在一个酒店里，一个豪华酒店。讨人嫌的富有游客们到达了。还有那些遭到剥削的员工。当然，其中的动态关系是，富有、白人的外来者是剥削者，但情况变得比这更加复杂。这是一部非常、非常精彩的剧。
And lurking, kind of thread running through it is the way in which native Hawaiian culture has been commodified, has been dissipated. That's right. Essentially kind of exists to make money from rich tourists. It's a tourist attraction, basically. Yeah. And I kind of watched it.
而在其中潜藏的、贯穿始终的一条线索，则是夏威夷本土文化被商业化、被消解的方式。没错。它基本上沦为了向富有游客赚钱的工具。基本上就是一个旅游景点。是的。然后我看了这部剧……
And there's kind of an incredibly moving sequence where there are Hawaiian, native Hawaiians, who are in a long boat and they're practicing. And one of the most miserable American characters in the series ends up becoming transfixed by this. And it's almost kind of redemptive in its quality. It's one of the few kind of it's a visual kind of statement of hope, almost of the sublime. And I watched it and realized I knew nothing at all about Hawaii, apart from the fact that Captain Cook died there.
其中有一个非常感人的片段，几位夏威夷原住民坐在一艘长船上进行划船练习。剧中最痛苦的美国角色之一，最终被这一幕深深吸引了。这种场景几乎带有一种救赎的品质。这是剧中为数不多的、具有视觉冲击力的希望表达，几乎带有一种崇高感。我看了之后，意识到自己对夏威夷一无所知，除了知道库克船长死在那里之外。
And that was basically the limit of my knowledge um so so i i kind of just basically skim read um a book on history on on hawaii and um i suppose because i'm british i i did find the the british thread in hawaiian history interesting because of course the flag of hawaii has a union jack on it i think it's the only oh yeah of course it's it's the only state flag in the united states that has a union jack um and that reflects that you know cook who who um was uh the first european to discover them although maybe the spanish got there first not for sure uh polynesian adventurers had got there in 10th 11th 12th centuries um cook arrives um it's predictably it all turns horrible um the introduction of european arms um the introduction of european
我的知识基本上就局限于此了。所以，所以我就基本上草草翻阅了一本关于夏威夷历史的书。嗯，大概因为我是英国人吧，我确实觉得夏威夷历史中的英国线索很有趣，因为当然，夏威夷的国旗上有一个米字旗。我想这是美国唯一……哦，对，当然，这是美国唯一一个国旗上有米字旗的州。这反映了这样一个事实：库克，他是第一个发现夏威夷群岛的欧洲人——尽管可能是西班牙人先到的，这并不确定；波罗的海探险家在公元10、11、12世纪就已经到达那里了——库克抵达了。不出所料，事情随之变得糟糕透顶。欧洲武器的引入，
diseases has its customary devastating effects uh all the chiefs of the various islands start fighting one another uh there's a great kind of series of battles and clashes. And in 1795, all the various islands of the Hawaiian archipelago get united under a king. And I'm going to apologies to any Hawaiian listeners if there are any out there. I know I'm going to mispronounce this, but he's called Kamehameha. Okay. I'll take a word for it. Kamehameha the Great.
欧洲疾病的引入，带来了习惯性的毁灭性影响；各个岛屿的酋长们开始互相厮杀；发生了一系列激烈的战役和冲突。到了1795年，夏威夷群岛的各个岛屿在一个国王的统治下统一了。我要向任何收听节目的夏威夷听众道歉，如果真的有的话。我知道我的发音肯定不标准，但他被称为卡米哈米哈（Kamehameha）。好吧。我就姑且信你这一回。卡米哈米哈大帝。
And he establishes a line of kings, all of whom take the name Kamehameha. So Kamehameha, the first, the second, the third, the fourth. And what happens over the ninth century is that Hawaii becomes increasingly part, kind of Anglo-Americanized. So there's both British and American influences. And the intersection point of that is Protestant missionaries. So Hawaii becomes Protestantized very, very quickly.
他建立了一个国王世系，所有后代都采用卡米哈米哈这个名字。所以有卡米哈米哈一世、二世、三世、四世。在19世纪发生的事情是，夏威夷越来越深入地融入了英美文化圈，同时受到了英国和美国的影响。而这二者的交汇点就是新教传教士。所以夏威夷非常、非常快地新教化了。
In 1840, it becomes officially a christian uh monarchy um and uh protestant missionaries kind of end up becoming key players in the in the politics of this hawaiian kingdom so they kind of marry into the local aristocracy they have children they become advisors and so on and this integrates the hawaiian monarchy into the kind aristocracy they have children they become advisors and so on and this integrates the hawaiian monarchy into the kind of the broader world of european and american geopolitics yeah so you have this king called um kamahamaha the fourth i knew he'd bar. So he's a very, very, very traveled man. When he's very young, before he becomes king, he's crown prince. He travels to France.
1840年，它正式成为了一个基督教君主国。而且新教传教士最终成为了这个夏威夷王国政治中的关键人物。他们通过联姻融入当地贵族，生下后代，成为顾问等等。这就将夏威夷君主制融入了更广阔的欧洲和美国的地缘政治世界中。对，所以当时有一位国王叫卡米哈米哈四世——我就知道他会卡壳。他是一个非常、非常喜欢旅行的人。在他很年轻的时候，在成为国王之前，他是王储，曾前往法国旅行。
He meets Louis Napoleon. He goes to England and he meets, he doesn't meet Queen Victoria because she's, I think, pregnant at the time and is retired. But meets Prince Albert, meets Lord Palmerston and then goes to america meets the president taylor yeah and then he's going back on the train across america and he goes into his private compartment because of course he's a king so he has a wonderful compartment and the conductor seeing that he's not white assumes that he's a servant who's strayed in there he shouldn't be there and upbraids him and tries to throw him off the train. And Kamehameha is obviously furious at this. And this is, I think, a sentiment calculated to make every Englishman proud. This is the first time I have ever received
他见到了路易·拿破仑。他去了英国，见到了……他没有见到维多利亚女王，因为我记得女王当时怀孕了并且已经退居幕后。但他见到了阿尔伯特亲王，见到了帕麦斯顿勋爵，然后去了美国，见到了泰勒总统。接着，他坐火车横穿美国准备返回。由于他是国王，他有自己的专属包厢——一个非常棒的包厢。列车长看到他不是白人，就以为他是一个误闯进来的仆人，认为他不应该待在那里，于是当众训斥他，并试图把他赶下火车。卡米哈米哈对此显然怒不可遏。我认为，这种情绪简直能让每个英国人都感到骄傲：“这是我生平第一次受到这种待遇，无论是在英国、法国还是其他任何地方。在英国，一个非洲人都可以支付车票，然后和维多利亚女王并肩而坐。”
such treatment, not in England or France or anywhere else. In England, an African can pay his fare and sit alongside Queen Victoria. Oh, that's very heartwarming. And you know the other heartwarming thing about Kamehameha? Who's a Wolves fan? No, he's a big cricket fan. He's a huge cricket fan. So there's a kind of fascinating
哦，这真是暖心。你知道卡米哈米哈还有什么暖心的地方吗？他是狼队（Wolves）的球迷吗？不，他是板球的超级粉丝。他是板球的超级大粉丝。所以，这其中有一个非常迷人的
glimpse there of what Hawaii might have been. A cricketing... A cricket playing part of the United Kingdom. Like Guernsey. Like guernsey like guernsey exactly anyway so what so what does this have to do with the 2nd of january well it has to do with the birth of the 2nd of january is the birth of um king kamahamaha the fourth's wife queen emma his wife is born on there yeah okay so she's born on january the 2nd 1836 um and her lineage is incredibly complicated involving incredibly hawaiian names that i do not really feel
一瞥，让我们看到夏威夷本来可能会成为什么样子：一个打板球的……一个属于联合王国的、打板球的地方。就像根西岛一样。就像根西岛，就像根西岛，完全正确。不管怎样，所以……这和1月2日有什么关系呢？这与……1月2日的诞生有关。1月2日是卡米哈米哈四世的妻子——埃玛女王（Queen Emma）的诞辰。他的妻子就是在那天出生的。是的，好吧，所以她出生于1836年1月2日。她的血统极其复杂，包含了许多我实在觉得……
so her full name is emma kalani kaumaka amano kalaleleonalaniinea Rook. Oh, your Hawaiian is beautiful. And the Rook is her stepfather. So she's born to very distinguished Hawaiian aristocracy. Then apparently it's the custom of the Hawaiian aristocracy that the children get adopted by step-parents and she gets adopted by an aunt of hers who doesn't have a child who's a chieftain in Hawaii and is married to somebody, a missionary called Dr. Thomas C.B. Rook. And Dr. Thomas C.B. Rook is English. He came from Hertfordshire, studied at St. Bartholomew's Hospital.
她的全名是：埃玛·卡兰尼·考毛卡·阿马诺·卡莱莱奥纳拉尼内亚·鲁克（Emma Kalani Kaumaka Amano Kalaleleonalaniinea Rook）。哦，你的夏威夷语说得太美妙了。其中的“鲁克”是她的继父。所以她出生于一个非常显赫的夏威夷贵族家庭。后来据说夏威夷贵族有个习俗，就是把孩子交给继父母收养。她被她的一位没有孩子的姑妈收养——这位姑妈是夏威夷的一位酋长，嫁给了一位名叫托马斯·C·B·鲁克（Dr. Thomas C.B. Rook）的英国传教士。托马斯·C·B·鲁克医生是个英国人。他来自赫特福德郡，曾在圣巴托洛缪医院学习。
And ends up marrying into the Hawaiian royal family. And he builds what every visitor to Hawaii says is the most English house outside England. Wow. It's the most English looking house. I'm going to Google his house right now. What's his name? Thomas Rook. Thomas Rook with an E.
并最终通过婚姻融入了夏威夷王室。他建造了一座房子，所有去过夏威夷的人都说这是英国本土以外最像英国的房子。哇。这是一座极具英国风格的房子。我现在就要去谷歌一下他的房子。他叫什么名字？托马斯·鲁克。带字母e的托马斯·鲁克（Thomas Rook）。
And so, so Emma grows up in this incredibly English house. And she marries, she marries a guy. It's quite English. It's only quite English. Well, that's his reputation.
所以，埃玛就是在这样一座极其具有英国风味的房子里长大的。然后她结婚了，她嫁给了一个家伙。这可真够英国的。只是“挺英国”吗？好吧，这就是他的名声。
Yeah. Don't spoil it for people. No, no, it's okay. It's very English. It's a very English house. It looks like a house from still on the world world exactly but i'll say that uh please you know
对。大家别剧透。不，不，没关系。这非常英国。这是一座非常英国式的房子。看起来就像是一座……完全就是世外桃源。不过我要说的是，请……
you know there are cricket nets for yeah for the king to practice his off breaks and you know it's absolutely brilliant um so um she married she so she marries the king of Hawaii. Yeah. And they have a son who they call Albert. Oh, very good. He was born in 1858. And do you know who Albert's godmother is? Queen Victoria. Yeah. Queen Victoria.
你知道的，那里有板球网，供国王练习他的切球。绝对棒极了。所以……她结婚了。她嫁给了夏威夷国王。是的。他们生了一个儿子，起名叫阿尔伯特。哦，非常不错。他出生于1858年。你知道阿尔伯特的教母是谁吗？维多利亚女王。是的。维多利亚女王。
Yeah. She agreed to do it. Yeah, she did. Oh, good for Queen Victoria. That railroad conductor in the US wouldn't have agreed, but Queen Victoria agreed. queen victoria that that railroad conductor in the u.s wouldn't have agreed but queen victoria agreed and um so her unfortunately the son albert um dies in 1862 and her husband dies the following year yeah so she you know she doesn't have a kind of official state she kind of remains a queen but she's no longer regnant yeah um so she devotes her life to philanthropy so she founds a hospital to help
是的。她同意了。是的，她确实同意了。哦，维多利亚女王真好。美国那个列车长肯定不会同意，但维多利亚女王同意了。维多利亚女王……美国那个列车长肯定不会同意，但维多利亚女王同意了。不幸的是，他们的儿子阿尔伯特在1862年夭折了，而她的丈夫也在次年去世。所以，她并没有一个正式的国家实权地位——她某种程度上依然保留着太后（Queen）的头衔，但不再是执政女王了。因此，她把一生奉献给了慈善事业。她创立了一家医院来帮助
hawaiians fight smallpox uh she sponsors education she's a great enthusiast for opera so she sings in the chorus of a performance of la traviata golly that's very impressive she's also a very devout anglican yeah so she uh she gets the Church of England to set up the Church of Hawaii as a kind of branch of the Church of England. 1862, she gets baptised into the Anglican Church. And then 1865 to 6,
夏威夷人抗击天花；她资助教育；她还是歌剧的狂热爱好者，甚至还在一场《茶花女》（La Traviata）的演出中参与合唱。天哪，这太令人印象深刻了。她还是一位非常虔诚的圣公会教徒。所以她促使英国国教会将夏威夷教会设立为英国国教会的一个分支。1862年，她受洗加入了圣公会。随后在1865年至1866年间，
she follows in her dead husband's footsteps by going on a grand tour of America and Europe. And she gets to meet Victoria. Oh, this is a nice moment. Yeah. And they get on tremendously.
她追随已故丈夫的脚步，开启了美国和欧洲的豪华大巡游。她得以见到了维多利亚女王。哦，这是一个美好的时刻。是的。而且她们相处得极其融洽。
Well, Victoria is very, very fond of her. She meets Napoleon the third. She winters on the, on the French Riviera. And then she comes back to Hawaii and in 1874, there's an election for the King because there,
维多利亚非常、非常喜欢她。她还见到了拿破仑三世。她在法国里维埃拉过冬。然后她回到了夏威夷。1874年，夏威夷举行了一场国王选举，因为当时
there's a kind of problem of, you know, there's not an obvious candidate. And Emma runs as one of the candidates, one of the two candidates and her right. So she's the an obvious candidate. And Emma runs as one of the candidates, one of the two candidates. And so she's the pro-British candidate and her rival is the pro-American candidate. Oh dear.
存在一个问题，就是没有一个显而易见的候选人。埃玛作为候选人之一参选，她是两位候选人之一。没错。所以她是一个显而易见的候选人。埃玛作为候选人之一参选，她是两位候选人之一。所以她是亲英派候选人，而她的竞争对手是亲美派候选人。噢天哪。
I don't like the way this is going, Tom. Okay. So Emma is the people's choice. Of course, people's princess. The people back Emma. They want her to be the queen. But the legislative assembly who've been bought by the yankee dollar back her rival this is a poor story so
我不喜欢事情这样发展，汤姆。好吧。所以埃玛是民心所向。当然，她是人民的公主。民众支持埃玛。他们希望她成为女王。但是被洋基美元收买的立法议会却支持她的对手。这真是一个糟糕的故事。所以
so uh this this american rival whose name is kalakaua becomes king what an absolute villain he becomes king well he's not actually he's you know he's not a villain he's a decent man um and he leaves a seat for her at every royal occasion so it's it's left for her it's easy to be magnanimous though yeah you know she keeps her title she's known as the old queen she might not like that i mean that doesn't sound to me like he's a tremendous fellow at all he seems like an absolute shit no i think the old queen is a term of great affection and respect. And, you know, and then she dies. I think that's a kind of wonderful story. So if she had won that election, do you think Hawaii would be British?
所以这位美国竞争对手——名叫卡拉卡瓦（Kalakaua）——当上了国王。真是个绝对的混蛋！他当上了国王。嗯，其实他也不是……他算不上什么混蛋，他是个正派人。而且他在每一次王室活动中都为她留着一个座位，座位总是给她留着的。不过慷慨大方倒是容易得很，对吧。你知道的，她保留了自己的头衔，被称为“老王后”。她可能不会喜欢这个称呼。我的意思是，听起来他根本不是什么了不起的家伙，他看起来简直是个绝对的混蛋。不，我觉得“老王后”是一个充满喜爱和尊重的称呼。而且，后来她去世了。我觉得这是一个非常棒的故事。所以，如果她赢了那场选举，你觉得夏威夷会变成英国领地吗？
Or would it be like the Falkland Islands or something? I think it would be a constitutional monarchy. Yeah, because what happened... And, you know know the cricket playing descendants of queen emma would be loyal members of the british commonwealth and it would all be tremendous you may not know the answer to this time but what happened to the hawaiian monarchy um basically um british and american business interests and chiefly american business interests um decided that the monarchy was getting in the way of uh what it wanted to do
还是会像福克兰群岛（Falkland Islands）那样？我觉得它会成为一个君主立宪制国家。是的，因为发生的……而且，你知道的，女王埃玛那些打板球的后代会成为英国联邦的忠实成员，一切都会变得妙不可言。你可能不知道这个答案，汤姆：夏威夷君主制后来怎么了？基本上，英国和美国的商业利益——主要是美国商业利益——认为君主制挡了他们的路，妨碍了他们想要做的事情，
of kind of um integrating it into uh the american economy and so they they toppled it oh that's very disappointing so basically toppled in the interest of capitalism yeah absolutely swept away by well i mean you know classic mar Very sad. Feudalism toppled. Hard-nosed capitalists move in. Okay. Well, that queues up very nicely tomorrow's choices. Because tomorrow,
也就是将其融入美国经济。于是他们推翻了它。哦，这太令人失望了。所以基本上是为了资本主义的利益而被推翻了。是的，绝对是被……被……好吧，标准的马克思主义历史观。非常遗憾。封建制度被推翻，精明的资本家接管。好吧，这就为明天的选择做好了完美的铺垫。因为明天，
I should be talking about a man who had a lot of time for monarchy and very little time for hard-nosed commercialism. And that man, Tom, is J.R.R. Tolkien. Brilliant. Very exciting. So, we shall see you tomorrow. Goodbye.R. Tolkien. Brilliant. Very exciting. So we shall see you tomorrow. Goodbye.
我将谈论一个对君主制充满温情、却对精明商业主义毫无耐心的人。而这个人，汤姆，就是J·R·R·托尔金（J.R.R. Tolkien）。太棒了。非常令人兴奋。那么，我们明天见。再见。R·托尔金。太棒了。非常令人兴奋。那么，我们明天见。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家番外、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。